so just for the
for the fun of it since you mentioned
let's go there briefly
about autonomous vehicles so one of the
companies in the space tesla
is work with andre karpathy and elon
musk are working on a system called
autopilot which is primarily a
vision-based system
with eight cameras and basically a
single neural network a multi-task
neural network
they call it hydro net multiple heads so
it does multiple
tasks but is forming the same
representation at the core
do you think driving can be converted in
this way
to uh purely a vision problem and then
solved within you with learning
or even more specifically in the current
approach
what do you think about what tesla
autopilot team is doing
so the way i think about it is that
there are certainly
subset subsets of the visual based
driving problem which are quite solvable
so for example driving in freeway
conditions
is uh quite a solvable problem i think
there were demonstrations of that going
back to the 1980s by
someone called ernst stickmans in munich
in the 90s there were approaches from
carnegie mellon there were approaches
from
our team at berkeley in the 2000s there
were approaches from stanford
and so on so autonomous driving in
certain settings is very doable
the challenge is to have an autopilot
work
under all kinds of driving conditions
at that point it's not just a question
of vision
or perception but really also of control
and dealing with all the edge cases
so where do you think most of the
difficult cases
to me even the highway driving is an
open problem because
uh it applies the same 50
90 95 99 rule or the first step
the fallacy of the first step i forget
how you put it
we fall victim to i think even highway
driving has a lot of elements
because to solve autonomous driving you
have to completely relinquish
the the fat help of a human being
you're always in control so that you're
really going to feel the edge cases
so i i think even highway driving is
really difficult but
in terms of the general driving task do
you think
vision is the fundamental problem or is
it
also your action the the interaction
with the environment
the ability to uh and then like the
middle ground i don't know if you put
that under vision which is
trying to predict the behavior of others
which is
a little bit in the world of
understanding the scene
but it's also trying to form a model of
the actors in the scene
and predict their behavior yeah i
include that in vision because
to me perception blends into cognition
and building predictive models of other
agents in the world
which could be other agents could be
people other agents could be other cars
that is part of the task of perception
because
perception always has to not tell us
what is now but what will happen
because what's now is boring it's done
it's over with
okay yeah if we care about the future
because we
act in the future and we care about the
past
and as much as it informs what's going
to happen in the future
uh so i think we have to build
predictive models of of
of behaviors of people and and those can
get quite
complicated so uh
i mean uh i i've seen examples of this
in
uh actually i mean i own a tesla
and it has various safety features built
in
and uh what i see are these examples
where
let's say there is some uh skateboarder
i mean
this i and i i don't want to be too
critical because
obviously this is these are the systems
are always being improved and
any specific criticism i have maybe the
system
six months from now will not have that
that that particular failure mode
so uh it
it had it had the wrong response and
it's because it couldn't predict
what what this skateboarder was going to
do
okay and because it really required that
higher level cognitive understanding
of what skateboarders typically do as
opposed to a normal pedestrian
so what might have been the correct
behavior for a pedestrian
a typical behavior for pedestrian was
not the typical behavior for a
skateboarder right yeah
and uh uh so so therefore
to do a good job there you need to have
enough data where
you have pedestrians you also have
skateboarders
you've seen enough skateboarders to see
what
uh what kinds of uh patterns of behavior
they have
so it is it is in principle with enough
data that problem could be solved
but uh i think our current
uh systems computer vision systems they
need far
far more data than humans do for
learning those
same capabilities so say that there is
going to be a system that solves
autonomous driving
do you think it will look similar to
what we have today
but have a lot more data perhaps more
compute but the fundamental
architectures involved
like neuro well in the case of tesla
autopilot is
neural networks do you think it will
look similar
in that regard and we'll just have more
data that's a
scientific hypothesis as to which way is
it going to go
uh i will tell you what i would bet on
uh
so and this is at my general
philosophical position on how these
learning systems have been
what we have found currently very
effective in computer vision
uh with in in the deep learning paradigm
is
sort of tabula rasa learning and tabular
us are learning
in a supervised way with lots and lots
of what's up
in the sense that blank slate we just
have the system which is
given a series of experiences in this
setting and then it learns there
now if let's think about human driving
it is not tabular assad learning
so at the age of 16 in high school
a teenager goes in to goes into driver
head class
right and now at that point they learn
but
at the age of 16 they are already visual
geniuses
because from 0 to 16 they have built a
certain repertoire of vision
in fact most of it has probably been
achieved by
age two right in in this period of age
up to age two they know that the world
is three-dimensional they know how
objects look like from different
perspectives
they know about occlusion they
know about common dynamics of humans and
other bodies
they have some notion of intuitive
physics so they
they built that up from their
observations and interactions
in early childhood and of course
reinforced through
their their growing up to age 16. so
then
at age 16 when they go into driver ed
what are they learning they're not
learning afresh the visual world
they have a mastery of the visual world
what they are learning is
control okay they are learning how to be
smooth
about control about steering and brakes
and so forth
they're learning a sense of typical
traffic situations
now the the that education process
can be quite short because they are
coming in as visual geniuses
and of course in their future they're
going to encounter situations which are
very novel
right so during my driver ed class
i may not have had to deal with a
skateboarder i may not have had to deal
with a truck
driving in front of me who's from
where the back opens up and some junk
gets dropped from the truck
and i have to deal with it right but i
can deal with this as a driver
even though i did not encounter this in
my driver at class
and the reason i can deal with it is
because i have all this general visual
knowledge and expertise
and do you think the learning mechanisms
we have today
can do that kind of long-term
accumulation of knowledge
or do we have to do some kind of
you know in the the the work that led up
to expert systems with knowledge
representation
you know the broader field of what of
artificial intelligence
worked on at this kind of accumulation
of knowledge do you think neural
networks can do the same
i think i don't see
any in principle problem with neural
networks doing it
but i think the learning techniques
would need to evolve significantly
so the current the current
learning techniques that we have is
are supervised learning you're giving
lots of examples xiy pairs and you
you learn the functional mapping between
them
i think that human learning is far
richer than that
it includes many different components
there are
there is a a child explores the world
and sees as for example a child
takes an object and manipulates it
in his or her hand and therefore gets to
see the object from different points of
view
and the child has commanded the movement
so that's a kind of learning data but
the learning data has been
arranged by the child and this is a very
rich
kind of data the child can do various
experiments with the world so
uh so there are many aspects of
sort of human learning and these have
been studied in in child development by
psychologists and they what they tell us
is that
supervised learning is a very small part
of it there are many different
aspects of learning and
what we would need to do is to develop
models of
all of these and then uh
train our systems in that with that kind
of
uh protocol so new new methods of
learning
yes some of which might imitate the
human brain
you